[inaudible] joining me today as a Canadian businessman,
lawyer,
member of parliament,
and the founder and head of the People's Party of Canada.
Maxine Bernay,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for the invitation,
Dave.
I'm very happy to be with you.
I am glad you're here.
I am pretty sure how many people are there in Canada,
roughly.
I turned 87 media and 37 so I've gotten about 36 million emails that you on the
show or on Twitter.
I mean everybody in Canada seems to want us to do this.
Sit down.
So,
so I'll do my best so we shall see what happens.
Okay.
There's many reasons that I'm looking forward to this chat.
And originally we were going to do this on Skype and then you were gracious
enough to say let's,
let's do this in person.
Um,
the fact that somebody in Canada is spreading the ideas of liberty and of the
individual and limited government,
all of those things is incredibly inspiring to me.
And it's war of what we need down here too.
But let's just start first with a little bit of your biography.
For people that don't know anything about you?
Yes.
Uh,
I'm a lawyer.
Um,
I did also of course in a businesses before,
um,
and I work in a private sector in Montreal,
Quebec,
uh,
in the financial sector.
I was VP of financial institutions.
And after that I work with the Montreal Economic Institute.
That's a free market think tanks,
like maybe the missus institute and the like that I was VP over there.
And in 2005,
um,
I had a meeting with Steven [inaudible] at that time.
He was the leader of the opposition before the election in 2006.
Uh,
and so he was looking for some ideas to be able to have some seats in Quebec.
As you know,
Quebec is the francophone part of the country.
And so we had a good chat together and I told him,
you know,
there's two important things that you must say to k Baker's if you want to win
first you must respect the constitution.
Because in Quebec,
if you remember,
we had the two referendum and uh,
we,
we still have a separate is a port,
it's called party at the provincial level.
So I told him,
you know,
respect the Canadian constitution,
don't interfere in provincial jurisdiction and everything will be okay.
And also lower taxes,
income tax,
a two k backers and all Canadians.
And at the end that was I think a good proposal for Quebec but also for,
uh,
all across the country.
And he decided to put that in his platform and he asked me to run with him in
2006.
So I decided to run.
And my writing,
my district,
it is in both near Quebec city.
It's Afa role,
f urban riding.
And I went there because my dad was an emp under Brian Maroney,
uh,
for uh,
13 years.
And so when I came in,
bought in 2006 a to run,
the director of my campaign told me,
Maxine,
we have a problem with you.
Uh,
because I was working in Montreal that was not tender writing.
It said,
you have a name.
My Dad was very well known,
but you don't have a first name.
So a goal at the end of the campaign,
people must know you.
So I did a good campaign and a at the end,
a one and all sorts.
Steven Opera.
We formed a Gartman in 2006 and minority government,
2008 a minority government.
And I was introduced to municipal at that time.
I did a big deregulation in telecom and that's why people are had that Dame,
the call me the uh,
Albert turn from Quebec because in Alberta they are very free markets.
And in Quebec at the plains Savalo we have a big fat and socialist government.
So,
and I do regret the telecom industry.
It was a big success.
And after that,
uh,
payments to our,
press me to be the finer fear and I was a foreign affair for a year and are
resigning.
And I came back in the cabinet in 2010.
And,
um,
I was a minister for Small Business and after dad,
a minister for a state for agriculture.
And so we had a majority government in 2000 and uh,
and uh,
11 and so we did some reform and after that in 2015 and two,
door went in power,
uh,
and uh,
and still a member of parliament and our per resigning as the leader of the
party and the fine is coming ray now because they decided to run for the
leadership and create after that,
I didn't win with the 49% of the votes and our wives,
they're mostly Bertoia and Kenny date.
And I had a very strong platform about individual freedom,
personal responsibility actually to four teams of our platform was individual
freedom,
personal restaurants,
MBT,
RF Becht and fairness.
And all our policies were based on these principles that was very successful at
49%.
And uh,
you know,
I was the only one to say we must abolish copwatch welfare.
While I'm good percent,
we might sort of saw card foreign aid and um,
and do a lot of changes like that on the economy and also on the immigration.
I had a strong platform,
so I didn't,
when I tried to work with the new leader,
um,
and we'll share,
uh,
trade to,
I wanted the leadership of the Conservative Party of Canada to add up some of
our reforms because that was very popular.
And a year later he told me that,
uh,
you didn't want me anymore.
They won't take any of our,
of the ideas that I put forward and our,
so I did couple of tweets that they didn't like,
uh,
I bought it to your dog.
And so,
um,
I resigned from the body and in September I decided to create the People's Party
of Canada.
Yeah.
All right.
So you're your basic yeah.
Political pedigree there.
Uh,
is there an inherent sort
of oddity of a libertarian trying to go into government where most people that
go into government want to grow government,
they believe that if only their policies were instituted,
they could have a better government that could do more and so on versus a
libertarian comes in,
you cut regulation,
you want it to cut some programs,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
It's almost like you're trying to shrink the thing that's also your job now.
You've had real jobs also.
So I suspect you could look at it perhaps a little bit differently.
Yeah.
Because you know,
it wasn't a private sector before and I know that too much government,
it is not bringing prosperity and um,
kind of an Australian economist also.
Uh,
I like muses and all the,
you know,
my,
my peripheral website is Mrs Org.
So I'm,
I'm,
I'm a on the economy,
I can call,
you can call me battalion.
Um,
but um,
I'm not a really be tie in because it really brought,
Diana will ask for a opening borders or a norm,
more regulations or legislation on drugs.
And so I don't believe in that.
I think we must have a status
that we'll have some regulation,
basic regulations.
How do you figure out where that line is that that's been one of the things that
I talk about with a lot of different guests and that sort of seems to be a
little bit of the difference between people who consider themselves classical
liberals and libertarians where there's a little more say,
hand of the state.
On the classical liberal side.
Libertarians,
it's hard to know where the,
where the end is.
Are we,
are we just in Mad Max Mad Max was sometimes they call you mad.
Yeah.
So,
so for me it's,
it's on a bod the economy,
uh,
that's the most important.
Uh,
and yes.
Um,
you know,
our social policies must be for more freedom and personal responsibility.
And I tried to make a big difference with the state and the economy like we did
in the past with the states and,
and religious,
you know,
uh,
so that's always important to have this a difference.
And on the economy it's easy to be a libertarian and Apollo,
it's easier to be a difficult tie in,
in a politician,
uh,
because you know,
it's all special interest group that are coming to you.
And they want a,
a privilege or a or a or a more,
uh,
more,
subsidies or things like that.
So I'm making the line when I'm seeing,
you know,
what me,
what I want,
I want to work for all Canadians and not for a special interest group.
And when,
I don't know a in,
in group is coming to us and they just one to promote their privilege or to keep
their privilege,
that will be easy for me to say,
no,
I won't do that.
The best example or was the cocktail that we have in Canada in a,
in a supply management,
that's a socialist system that Pierre Trudeau put forward 45 years ago where a
meal can pull tree and eggs.
The producers fixing the price and fixing the production for the Canadian
market,
they cannot export.
So Canadians are paying twice the price for a meal,
poultry and eggs.
If you compound that with the price that you're paying here in the US.
So these cartel is very powerful.
And when they came to me and they wanted to keep their privilege,
I say,
no,
you know,
we'll abolish that.
We'll have a transition period.
You'll be able to export.
I believe in a real free market.
It's,
if a free market is good for every industry,
mostly be good also for these people.
So.
So what's the counter argument on that though?
We've trued,
oh now,
yeah.
Not The old Trudeau,
but if our current Trudy,
yeah,
was giving the counter argument on why you wouldn't free that up.
Is that just because he doesn't believe in free market economics,
but it's because it's a powerful lobby and I'll Saudia one to keep seats also.
And they are very powerful in rural areas in the country and uh,
and so far they're powerful.
Second,
uh,
he is buying in their arguments that,
you know,
uh,
if we have meal from the u s or eggs from the US,
that won't be the same quality.
And we need to stop that for being sure that we can control the quality of our
products.
And so that's another argument.
But for me,
you know,
when you have a legislation,
uh,
everybody in most respect dad,
so if you want to export to Canada,
your eggs or your poetry or your milk,
you must follow the Canadian legislation and regulation.
That's a,
that's a no deal.
And uh,
but it's,
it's,
it's the powerful,
they're very powerful.
So the thinking is they want to keep,
not only to adore but are also my former party,
the conservative party of Canada,
the NDP.
Also the,
they are too afraid to uh,
to just just listen to Canadians.
They think that all we have a good system and they think that can again,
the,
the thing that can Indians don't understand that system.
They didn't,
that Canadian don't understand that they are paying twice the price.
So the more I speak about that,
the more popular it is.
And that was very important in my campaign for the leadership.
And it is also part of our platform right now.
So answering your questions,
why it all want to keep that cartel iding it's only for political reason.
So is the idea of liberty and personal responsibility and some of the other
things that you're running on are these oddly new in Canada.
And I say that because when,
when you started coming on my radar about a year ago,
I saw people started tweeting about you.
There were a lot of people saying something to the effect of,
wow,
if a libertarian is needed in Canada,
then something really must be wrong there as if there was no need for it for a
long time.
But maybe something unique is happening now.
Yeah.
And people are ready for the new ideas.
And I think people are fed up with traditional politicians that are seeing
something,
a d and d opposing the auditee,
a politician that tried to please the special interest group.
So what I'm doing,
you know,
I'm doing politics differently and uh,
there is no political correctness,
uh,
for our party and seeing what,
what must be said for better policies in this country in Canada.
Sorry.
And so the,
um,
I think people are ready and,
and what's happening actually right now,
you know,
it's good to have the right ideas,
but it's good.
It's better to have the right ideas at the right time.
And I think the timing is very good for us,
for me because we have a government in a,
in a Taiwan right now are to total Gutterman that Horace spending on a ton of
money,
huge defecit people they don't see and we don't know when they will balance the
budget.
Uh,
it must be around 20,
24,
uh,
and everybody knows that,
that the different set of today or the taxes of tomorrow.
So a huge deficit,
huge taxes,
you know,
Taiwan and you kind of need is social right now in Canada.
So people are looking for a kind of alternative and a,
and I think that timing is good for me because,
uh,
in a,
in a Paul 57% of Canadians said,
and maybe a month ago that they're ready to vote for a new party.
So we are a very new party for months and month old and they are ready to vote
for a new party and not voting for the traditional parties.
Something is happening.
18 kit,
the big government in Ottawa,
every time putting a lot of regulations and a lot of subsidies to businesses.
Uh,
you know the governor,
they're loud.
Did GM a couple of years ago,
more than two point $5 billion and GM said,
uh,
two months ago that they will leave Canada.
So it's a waste of money and we're giving a lot of money to big businesses and
all the other politicians are saying,
yeah,
it's all key.
We Must Elf business.
What I'm saying,
yes we might l businesses,
but every businesses having a fair policy that is to lower taxes to every
businesses and not giving a subsidies and beaking winner and loser.
So I think people are ready for a change.
They're seeing what's happening in our country and they know that we're not
going in the right direction right now.
So let's talk a little bit about regulation,
because I think a lot of people think,
especially if they're on the left right now,
they think if you say,
I'm cutting regulation,
well first they go to environmental regulations.
Yeah.
I think that's what they think first.
So I do want to ask me about that.
Yeah.
But also they think if you're just talking about a purely at a business level,
then that means that capitalism will then run a mock call.
It,
you know,
that all of these businesses will then start dumping in the rivers and doing
shady deals with each other and competition will be crushed and all of those
things.
So you want to do business or,
or environment first on the regulation front.
Yeah.
I think let's do,
let's do business first and then,
yeah.
And then let's do business first.
Uh,
you know,
business most answered the needs of consumers.
So consumers are asking for better products and for a m products that's,
that will respect the environment.
Uh,
that's why they are asking for electric cars.
And so you don't always need regulation to force that.
The free markets,
the,
uh,
the wish of the people will force businesses to adapt their practice in the
right way.
And so when you have,
when you have a real free market and when you have competition,
it's always good at the end for the consumers.
You'll have a better products and you'll have a lower prices.
But at the same thing,
the way,
at the same time,
the way that they are producing their products will change.
Right now,
you know,
people the best.
And some people are telling me,
you know,
we must have a,
cooperate to a social,
uh,
um,
corporate.
I do call that corporate social or corporate welfare.
No one will corporate social identity,
a corporation,
my son be socially well.
Oh,
they have like the social awareness,
social awareness.
And I said,
you know,
not really because a corporation first must make profits.
If they don't make any profit,
the they won't.
They won't be able to do anything.
So if they are profitable,
it's because you want their peak consumer consumers who wants their goods and
products.
So that's the first goal of our cooperation.
To make products and I think that you need regulation.
But,
uh,
what we're doing right now,
every time that something happened,
we put a new regulation,
but they must be a responsible of their actions,
corporations and individuals or that that's important for me.
And I think Canadian understand that.
Yeah.
What about on the environmental side?
I think this is the big one.
I think you've been for people who can understand free market economics.
It's a little bit more,
people think you just can't leave this environmental issues up to two private
companies.
Yeah.
You know,
you can sue a corporation if they don't respect the regulations.
Actually,
you know,
clean the water.
It's very important.
But you know,
uh,
when you have facilities that are owned by the government or by the
municipalities,
uh,
everything must be public.
If they're doing tests and,
and things like that.
Uh,
if the water is been on night,
when it's not public,
you cannot,
uh,
you cannot sue them if they don't,
if they don't respect the regulation.
So I remember that Margaret,
or in Europe,
the way to clean water over there was to have a regulation saying every test
that you're doing and that was done by municipalities or public entity must be
public and you will be responsible to be sure that you respect the regulations.
Should she just put a resolution on that?
Every test was public and five years later the wider Watsky nerd.
I didn't,
it was before because he didn't want to be sued.
They didn't want to be so,
so they were responsible.
So when you have a real free market,
when everything is on the table and you know the information that's bring,
usually a better quality of the water or land.
And so you have property right for that and property rights.
It's the basics of,
of all that.
But speaking about the environment now,
the debate in Canada,
it's climate change.
Yeah.
So,
so everybody wants to do something about climate change.
And I'm the only party who said,
you know,
we won't do anything,
uh,
environment in car data share jurisdiction with provinces and the federal
government.
And I don't believe in the Paris accord.
I don't believe that Canada would be able to achieve the goals that they put
into Paris accord.
And actually,
uh,
the UN and the radical environmental in Canada that said the same thing,
that Twitter one to impose a carbon tax of $20 a ton and he must impose a carbon
tax off at least $200 a time if you want to achieve his target.
So at $20 at times it will be on there.
Distortion for the economy and odd working families would appear with PR your
prices.
So that's why,
you know,
I don't believe in Paris accord and I think that we must not impose Paul's new
regulation on that.
We must lead provinces and a provincial government if they want to have a cap in
trade like they have here in the US and other kind of a process for that.
For us,
uh,
I want to have a program that will maybe be very strong on Clearwater or clear
here,
something that people understand and having the property to rates,
uh,
that will work and more information.
You need more than
formation at the same time to be sure that people won't understand if this lake
is clear on that.
Yeah.
So I'm glad you mentioned that because it seems to me that it's about
information and being able to get your messaging across.
So for example,
the Paris accords,
which obviously the United States pulled out of it seems very easy.
If you listen to the media,
it was very easy.
We have to be part of the Paris accords.
And then if you ask anyone what the Paris accords are,
they have no idea.
If you ask them when was was a binding,
is there any,
you know,
um,
is there anyone watching to make sure any of them this happens?
They have no idea in the answer's no.
I just read last month that despite the,
uh,
despite the US pulling out of the accords,
that right now the US is meeting most if not or exceeding all of the standards
of the,
of course.
So how much of this is just about getting your messaging across because,
uh,
this will shift us a little bit to talking about the media,
which you've had an interesting relationship with.
Yeah,
you're right about that.
You know,
it's all about to virtue senior link for a politician.
And,
but I think Canadian understand that they understand when I'm seeing,
you know,
the total government,
I truly,
right now there are a procreate or saying something to the population knowing
that he won't be able to achieve that.
So I prefer to tell the truth thing,
you know,
we won't sing that and we won't do to achieve that and we won't spend two point
$3 billion to send that to African countries to El them to fight climate change.
I think we must help Canadian first.
So that's part of our platform.
But the other party,
like the Conservative Party also,
they don't want to have a carbon tax when they want to impose more regulations,
uh,
on Canadian businesses.
And that's not the solution.
But they,
they try to please maybe the media,
but also a portion of the population.
And I think that,
you know,
when you explained,
and that's what I like in politics,
you know,
I like to explain our policies and why we are,
we are having the right policies based on freedom and response.
Lbt and when you explain that,
the more you explain,
I think the better people understand it and do more,
um,
uh,
more people will want to vote for our party.
So for me,
when I'm the only one to speak against the Paris accord,
uh,
there are a huge clientele there and it won't hurt me.
It will help me at the end.
And,
uh,
and you know,
my,
my deal with Canadians is be true.
Tell what you believe in and have some debates,
real debates.
And that's important for me.
So yes,
the media are playing an important role,
but we need to use all sorts of social media and that's why,
you know,
uh,
I'm very pleased to be here to speak to the American audience and Canadians
audience and just tried to have a conversation with them anew.
Yeah.
Well,
what's the state of the media?
Yeah,
you guys have,
you guys have a whole different set of problems than what is going on with the
CBC and just everything else in Canada.
I know we have to CBC,
like how your whole body language.
Yeah.
We have to CBC and the Federal Government is giving about one point $3 billion a
year to the state,
uh,
broadcast or to CBC.
And in French it's heads you Canada.
And I'm the only politician and it's,
it's a very popular policy that we must cut that because it is unfair to CBC are
competing with other private broadcaster,
uh,
for the advertising,
and also the received money from the government.
So it is not fair.
We must cut the CBC and a,
and what I want,
I want the CBC to be a little bit like a PBS in the state.
If they're so good,
they will be able to have money from their viewers.
But also the CBC,
uh,
their editorial board are a little bit,
I will be very,
uh,
very kind look a bit the left ear.
So,
yeah.
So very,
Yeah.
And uh,
it's worse in French door.
They're agile.
Canada in French are a more left ears then CBC sometimes.
So is there a reason for that?
You know,
uh,
it's like your media here.
It's a bit,
but,
but the worst thing is it is funded by the government.
So if you're a,
I dunno,
a CNN and you don't receive any fumble,
you government and you want to to be on the left,
if it's your corporate decision,
but the CBC must be more neutral and they are not.
So that's the big problem that we have in Canada.
The way to fix that,
it's first of all,
CBC must be a must receive money from the viewers first and second.
Uh,
the government,
if the government is giving money to CBC,
we must know the,
uh,
what's happening and maybe the executive of the CBC must be before the
parliament once a year to explain their editorial policy.
But that being said,
uh,
the media,
we have the CBC,
we have the traditional media.
But when you're a real conservative or right wing politician,
uh,
you don't have the same coverage than the,
the Liberals or the left.
Uh,
they're having in these traditional media,
do you think in a weird way that that's working to your favor now?
Because at least in the circles that I can see,
you seem to be the hottest Canadian politician despite the fact,
and it's,
maybe it's fueled by,
maybe it's not despite maybe because of the fact that you're the outsider from
the media and people are so fed up with the media that it's like,
oh,
here,
here's this guy doing it,
you know,
circumventing them.
And also,
you know,
when the media,
the traditional media or writing something about us or my party,
that is not true.
I will call that.
I will.
Uh,
and I'm very,
very factual on,
on,
on social media and Twitter about it.
And,
uh,
you know,
I don't try to please everybody or I don't know how to please the media.
They have to do a job.
If they are fair,
it's okay.
If they are not fair,
I will be out there.
And,
uh,
and I will,
I will argue my case.
And that's not all,
all the Polish and the Polish.
I'm not doing that.
They want to be fine with the media.
They don't want to have a fight with the media.
And for me,
I to have a fight with a jaundiced,
uh,
if a is not doing his job.
And I think people,
I appreciate that.
So yes,
when they're doing something,
not,
um,
objective on our policies,
on my party,
that can help me at the end because you know,
the credibility of journalists,
it is not the same with people like you on social media.
People have another way to find your news and they're a little bit more critics,
a tower,
the traditional journalists and yes,
I agree with you.
That can help me.
Yeah.
As a politician,
are you able to debate some of your political opponents these days?
I mean,
does anyone in Canada put these kinds of talks on a television where you can
actually get into the ideas with some of the people that you disagree with?
No,
usually when I'm on the traditional TV in Canada,
it's all about,
you know,
five minutes,
six minutes you don't want to get yeah.
Sounds like,
yeah,
yeah.
They wanted the only to have it.
And they don't give you enough time to insert the questions and then to go
deeper in the subject.
Uh,
but that's why I use social media.
That's why I'm prison in social media.
So,
but you know,
I need to deal with that and I think it's going very well right now.
So how does this all link to just sort of a state of free speech in Canada
because there does something seem to be something particularly unique in Canada,
which is why I've had so many Canadian guests and why Canada is usually our
second or third most viewed country.
Obviously there was the Jordan Peterson incident with [inaudible].
Yeah,
there's what happened with w uh,
Lindsay Shepherd at Wilfrid Laurier.
Yay.
You've got Gad sat up there.
Who's,
who's always fighting the battle of free speech.
Is there something,
is there,
is this new,
what's happening related to political correctness in Canada?
Yeah.
I think first of all,
that started 40 years ago in the university in Canada,
like in the US.
But now what's happening,
there are some politicians who believe in that and with that motion m one or
tree to be able to see 16.
Now these people that were,
that were on the at school couple of years ago,
40 years ago now,
some of them are politicians and,
uh,
you have this debate right now and it's,
it's good for us that we have Jordan Peterson and people like that.
Um,
we must fight,
I think,
when must not take for granted in Canada or freedom of expression and free
speech and,
and we must fight.
And I'm doing that as a politician.
Uh,
and you know,
would,
would that build see 16,
that was crazy.
Bill.
You know,
Jordan,
they want to force his Jordan to,
uh,
speak with a trans or gender.
Uh,
not he or she bought,
what was the word?
Oh,
it was whatever they want.
Whatever they want.
Yeah,
yeah.
But there no obligation.
You know,
there's no obligation to please everybody.
And that's what this all comes down to though,
that people just don't understand it.
And the fundamental responsibility of government in a freezer side.
I mean,
if we were boiling all this into one thing,
that seems to me to be it.
Yeah.
You don't want the government to tell you what to do.
You don't want the government to tell you what to say.
You know,
it's the basics of our democracy.
And actually,
you know,
one of our candidate,
look,
I Lynn,
because we're,
we have a f three by elections in Canada at the end of February,
the 25th of February.
And I will have candidates and people are party of Canada.
We'll have candidate.
And one of our candidates look alien in BC,
um,
uh,
Brunette BBC.
In that writing,
she add the Prion Shola Ball,
uh,
fied for,
um,
uh,
gender against the gender fluidity in BC in discord.
It's a provincial jurisdiction they wanted to teach at school,
to young kids that if you're a boy,
you may not be a boy.
And if you're a,
you may not be a girl and you can choose your sex.
The state wants to impose that and to teach that to young people and local inch
and no,
I don't want that.
I don't want the state to tell us what to do in.
That must be the responsibility of the parents.
So you don't have to put that in the mind of a young boys,
six or seven or five years old.
So,
but when she decided to be our candidate,
all the mainstream media as all Bernie and I said,
you know what,
she has the right to our own opinion and that's a great debate that they had at
the plant show level.
Now she's doing politics.
I've definitely lovable.
But you know,
they were,
they were trying to look at her like,
you know,
she may be a crazy Kenny Dade because she,
she,
she has some,
some opinions and strong opinions.
But you know,
because I believe in freedom of speech and our candidates can have opinions like
that.
We have candidates that are pro choice.
We have Kenny deeds that are poor life by just staying to doing the liberals.
They don't want any pro life candidates.
So for me,
my party must be like the,
the uh,
our Canadian society.
So yes,
I will tolerate different point of view,
but people must be all behind our programs.
A program that's very important.
But yes,
we have these debates right now in Canada about the state imposing some,
some values that a,
I think that's not the role of government.
Is it actually part of the policy of the Trudeau government that you,
if you're pro life that you actually can't be,
you know,
it's still in the party platform.
It's a party platform.
If you're a pro life person,
you cannot be a candidate for the Liberal Party of Canada.
And just staying to the door said that.
But you know that government is all obsessed by sex and gender.
Yeah.
Uh,
oh yeah.
The,
the,
the last budget,
you know,
that it was a gender budget.
The,
the,
I think what does that even mean?
But like when that meaning they didn't have a lot of economic data in the
budget,
you supposed to be a budget supports for the economy.
It can make data and then have a lot of economic data.
But I think the word gender was in the budget.
300 good times.
So,
and,
and the F are,
we'll give you an example.
If you want to build a pipeline in Canada with the new bill c 69,
you need to do,
uh,
enter a sectorial sex and gender analysis.
Don't ask me what that means.
And Terrell section,
section section or sex and gender analysis that's in the legislation.
So the sex and gender to build a pipeline to build pipeline.
And a lot of people were talking about this when we were in Alberta.
Yeah.
The sex and gender expert.
We'll look at the impact of building a pipeline in a rural community with Nan
and woman and [inaudible].
And so it's crazy.
It's a nonsense.
It's crazy.
So,
and this government is obsessed about that.
And I think that's why people are looking for an alternative.
So,
so a guy like Trudeau,
it's hard to judge what's really going on in someone's mind,
but do you think he really believes in the things that he's saying when it comes
to all of this gender stuff?
Or is it just that it always leads to bigger government and what he wants
fundamentally is bigger government because he wants more power.
He believes in state power.
Yeah.
So,
so that it's almost like it's a,
it's an ends.
The ends justify the means.
It's like you'll just say anything about gender and all these things.
I think he probably kind of believed him,
but at the end they just give him more power.
I think first of all,
he believe it.
And I think also it's because he believe in big government that will fix every
problem in our society.
Uh,
that's his philosophy.
And you know,
when he said that,
you know,
I don't know where Canada is,
no car identity or Canada is the first post national estate.
You know,
people did,
did the oldest standing Canada that we,
we are a nation,
we all know that post nation state we are,
we have Canadian values and we share the western civilization values.
So for him is a little bit like his father,
you know,
the UN and the world is important and the mass immigration and open borders and
everybody,
everybody can come to Canada.
Uh,
that's what people,
they don't like that in Canada.
They want us to respect our immigration system and adding a sustainable
immigration system.
So to know adding wants to build a big government.
And at the end he believed in a supra national government.
Uh,
you know,
he,
uh,
he just signed in 2010,
with the UN,
there's the UN Un a u n parliamentary assembly.
It's a,
it's a group that prolonged to promote a world government,
like the,
uh,
the EU parliament that will be able to,
write legislation that will be biding with and with the countries and they will
lost their serenity and Trudeau in 2010,
uh,
promote that and believe in that.
So it's all about the UN.
It's on about the big government.
And,
uh,
it's all about him trying to find the right policies that will solve every
problems.
But that's not the case.
Just less regulation,
more freedom.
You'll have more prosperity and in people are tired of that in Canada.
It almost strikes me as it's like a psychological condition more than anything
else.
It's just like sort of like,
it's obvious to me that you believe in just that the individual can,
yeah.
To the best of their ability,
solve their problems.
Not all of them,
but to the best of breed.
Absolutely.
And I think this other set of people believe that,
I don't know.
I would view it as almost a very dim way of viewing humans that if all weren't
controlled,
that endless evil would spread everywhere or something to that.
I think they believe that Canadians are children and you know,
they must follow regulation and you,
but I trust,
you know,
I have faith in people.
I failed,
that they have the ability,
the dignity and the right to make their own decision and determine their own
destiny.
That's important for us.
That's important for me.
And yes,
you can make,
can make a mistake,
but you will be responsible of your success and your,
your,
your mistake.
That's how you learn in a society.
Uh,
that's why,
you know,
uh,
speaking about that,
people like me a little bit and they'll,
they're looking at Jordan Peterson and the single Bernie personal
responsibility.
And Jordan also is his book.
It's all about that,
you know,
clean your,
your house,
your room before,
before cleaning the,
the world.
So,
so be responsible of your action.
And that's what we want to do.
And that's what,
as a politician,
I want to,
I want to do,
well,
I mentioned it before we sat down,
but I may as well say it on camera that when I go to these events and with
Jordan and especially in the 12 or 15 we did in Canada,
I say something about Trudeau and the whole audience blues.
I say something about you in the holiday.
It's goes crazy.
So,
so something good is happening.
Um,
you've mentioned,
uh,
borders a couple of times.
This does seem to now be the hot one,
at least in the United States where we seem to be caught between either a wall
or open borders.
And it's such an,
it's not a real choice.
I don't think.
It's not a sensible choice.
And in one hand,
if you're for the wall,
they say you're racist.
If you say you're for open borders,
then you're an anarchist or whatever it is.
So what would be the right way to look at borders if you want to maintain your
national sovereignty?
And that's the debate that we're having right now in Canada because as you know,
we have people who are crossing the border,
uh,
from the state of New York to Quebec.
And,
um,
the,
they are asking to this,
they said that they're refugees and actually down,
not really refugees.
You know,
your life is not indentured in the state of New York.
Uh,
but that being said,
they think it is.
They didn't proceed.
Proceed.
Yeah.
But,
um,
but,
uh,
the last two years,
I think more than 40,000 people across the border illegally.
So the Trudeau government doesn't want to fix that.
And that's a big issue in Canada.
So,
uh,
what I'm asking,
as a politician,
we have an immigration system and that is it.
By it.
It was going very well at points systems.
So it's a privilege to be Canadians and we want people who come here to share
our Canadian values are basic western civilization values and,
and it's a privilege.
So we have tree kind of immigrants in Canada,
the reunification of family,
the refugees and the economy can be grander person that will come because they
have a job because the business wasn't able to find a Canadians for that job.
So they coming,
they have a job and usually tease you and 20 greater society if you have a job.
But we don't need to build a wall between Canada and us.
We just need to be sure to respect our immigration system.
And the way to do that,
it's to have a discussion with president Trump about the third safe country
agreement.
We in a,
we have an agreement with us about that and to fix that glue ball.
So people who are crossing at a real point of entry,
it's all cared what people who are crossing and not a real point of entry.
Uh,
we in the most go back to the u s and we must have an agreement with the US
about that.
And I think we can have that cannot agreement if we sit with the n the Trump
administration.
But at the same time,
we must be clear that people who are coming to Canada most come from the right
reason.
And these people who are crossing our border right now,
40% of them will have to be the port because they're not real refugees.
So it's a big cost for Canadian tax payers because these people will be deported
maybe in two years from now.
So we must fix that.
And we have a strong position in our platform.
Yes,
we'll fix that at the border,
but we need,
don't need to impose a wall.
We don't need to create a war.
But the most important,
and we need to focus on more economy can be grants.
That's what we need in Canada.
And a little bit less of refugees and other little less of reunification of
family.
So that's a strong position.
But seeing that,
uh,
yes,
it's a risk in Canada when they see that as a politician.
Um,
but I'm taking that risk and uh,
yeah.
What,
what do you make of the libertarian argument that is pro open borders?
Because I've had many guests that are libertarian that take that position.
I've never been convinced of it.
I actually,
I just,
I don't understand the fundamental premise because as you said earlier,
it's,
if you're a nation,
a nation has borders,
that's just otherwise everything is just an amorphous blob.
But I'm sure you hear this arbitrary in circles.
So what do you make of that argument that's not coming from the left that's
coming from [inaudible]?
Yeah,
absolutely.
So our body is,
we're not anti immigration and we're not open borders and for mass immigration.
So what do we want?
It's a little bit less immigrant,
250,000 a year.
Like we add under Stephen Harper,
not 350,000 a year to do increase into door government.
The increase that by,
uh,
um,
40%.
So what I'm seeing when people say,
Oh,
you know,
open border is good.
It's not,
it's not everybody that can be part of a nation if you don't support of values.
If you are,
I don't know,
pro,
uh,
sharia law,
that's against our values.
That's again,
freedom,
uh,
between men and woman,
equality between men and woman.
The respect of the rule of law.
If you want to impose a new rule of law or Sharia law,
uh,
the integration one be very well in our society.
So these people,
uh,
they,
they must share our values,
our western civilization values.
So that's why if you have an open border and you on everybody from everywhere to
come to Canada,
that will create tension and dislike in the population.
And that's happening actually in Europe actually right now.
Are you able to point to that?
That's the one thing that I've never understood that Europe is having all of
these integration problems.
Merkle has basically said she screwed up.
Yeah.
You know,
after letting a million people in,
are you able to point to that and say,
you see they might have.
That's the warning I am doing that.
You know,
John is on telling our,
telling me maximi nothing happened in Canada.
It's a great country.
I said,
yes,
it is a great country,
but our one this country to be like that in 20 years from now.
So that's why we must have the discussion right now.
And people who are coming to Canada much more share our values.
If not,
you know,
they're not welcome because the integration will be very difficult.
And that's,
that's the Trudeau government policy on extreme reticular tourism.
So you know,
for twiddle,
diversity is our strength,
the strength.
And for me it's unity.
Who is our strength as a country and by Trudeau is always pushing for more
diversity,
more diversity,
more diversity.
And I said that and I tweet about that more diversity.
What else?
Our country at the end,
it will destroy our country.
I know that we,
there's Canada is a diverse country with people coming from different countries
and with different culture.
But at the end,
the integrated our society because they believe in our freedom,
in our values,
in a,
and they want to share,
uh,
our traditions and our irritated celebrate are irritated.
So that's what we want and we need to have that discussion in Canada.
And I think that discussion actually.
So that's why I don't believe in open borders.
I think it will create a tune,
much diversity.
And I want people to come in our country to share our values.
And it's a privilege to be Canadians and uh,
uh,
like it's a privilege to be an American.
So we must choose are immigrants.
And we did that for the last 35 years and that was very successful for our
country and people.
And it's interesting,
you're only trying to roll it back to what it was 40% less.
I mean,
it's not like you're doing something,
it's not like you're saying,
we're not letting anyone in a hundred people that are coming and it's going back
to,
well years ago.
Yeah.
And it is just statehood or is radical because the last Paul in Canada,
49% of Canadians said that they want fewer immigrants and only 6% 6% of Canadian
said that he wanted more immigrants.
So who is the reticle?
Maxime Bernie or just frantically?
It was just central to increase that by 40% so that's a fact.
And,
and that's what can do an Itin they're fed up with.
It's extremely,
extremely,
it's a good journalism.
Uh,
the cold of diversity.
you know,
it too much is too much.
And I think Canadian can see that in the future.
If you go on,
on,
on that road,
we'll have more problem and the integration would be more difficult.
And uh,
but am the 10 team immigrants and people came in our country and the build this
country,
so,
and,
but they came for the right reason and they're proud to be Canadians,
but the liberals and,
and the conservative are doing identity politics and they tried to please every
special enter as good,
but every special ethnic groups also.
So,
you know,
and they call that outreach.
Um,
but for me,
the policies must be the same for every Canadians.
And we don't do any difference with your race,
your gender or what.
So for us it is not important,
but the Kenyan govern is playing,
like explaining that,
that,
uh,
that they,
they're doing these policies and I think that wanted,
that won't be good at the end for our country.
Yeah.
So speaking of these policies,
I've also seen you on Twitter.
You're not a big fan of what's going on at the UN these days.
No,
I'm [inaudible] to say the least.
Uh,
can you,
can you lay out why the UN,
why,
why you're so down on mean by,
it's,
it's a,
it's first of all,
it's a dysfunctional organization.
Um,
just as example,
I think the last two years they've ordered 21 resolutions against Israel on
human rights and only one or two resolutions.
Again,
Shane or Cuba or,
or venues.
Lilla so,
you know,
and the countries that horror on that human raid committees,
uh,
are,
you know,
all the bad guy.
Yeah.
It's all the bad guys and Iraq,
uh,
China,
all,
all the bad guy,
all the dictatorships.
So,
so it's,
it's a joke and,
but you on one to impose their vision of the world on other countries.
And uh,
you know,
I was against recently a,
against the Compact on migration and then unity.
Do you want Migraines to be normal?
It is not normal.
People must be able to live in their country.
We must try to bring peace and prosperity.
And that's,
that's the most important.
But no,
they want that to be normal there.
There's two,
one good and 15 million people that are migrants,
uh,
on the globe and they want to facilitate that.
So,
and a total government signing that agreement,
but it was the worst thing or it's not binding.
It's not binding but at the end.
And why signing an agreement.
And if you said that you will follow all that,
but yeah,
it's not binding,
but you will put legislation in place to be inline with the agreement that you
signed.
So that will have an effect on our country at the end.
It won't be imposed by the UN.
It will be imposed by a illegitimate,
uh,
elected Kennedy and government.
So it's ironic because the Paris accord was non binding to,
and he was all about the parents.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
you're right.
So I think people there,
and I think I was very clear about that and uh,
I had a lot of support about that,
that migrant a Compaq and people understand that,
you know,
we have our syringe as a country and we must be able to select our immigrants.
And so that's coming from the UN.
So yes,
you're right.
Uh,
I don't like the UN.
I think that they are not so efficient and um,
and I'm clear about that.
Yeah.
Do you guys have a strain,
you know,
we're seeing in Europe now where there's nationalist parties that there does
seem to be a stream of sort of ethno nationalism or something that has a
different racial kind of couch connotation to it.
Do you guys have a strain of that in Canada?
Because it seems to me that I think what's happening and we're starting to see
it here,
is that if the,
if the good liberals and,
and the good libertarians and the people who just want to live and let live,
if they don't start making some advances against this radical leftism that's
moving,
there's going to be a lot of people that break in a bad way.
Yeah.
And in a weird way,
I wouldn't be able to blame them.
And I say that as someone that has no racism in my home,
but they would be left with no alternative as they watched their country
crumble.
Do you have any of that in Canada?
No,
we don't.
And it's a good news.
But at the end,
that's why we must have these discussion and,
and I don't fear to have the discussion for meters.
No political correctness.
There's no taboo subject.
And we need to have the discussion and,
and having that discussion with Canadians,
and I think it is time to have the discussion if we wait too long,
that can happen in our country.
Yeah.
So,
so right now I would imagine there's probably some people on the right that are
saying,
well burn,
Yay.
If he gains too much strength,
it'll sort of split the right and then that gives us truck,
I mean this is always the argument against Libertarians,
right?
Yeah.
And I say this as someone that goes,
I voted for Gary Johnson,
you know,
and I get it.
If the more at,
at some micro level when the third parties,
usually the libertarian party,
that's usually going to take from the conservatives more than the lefties and
then then there is an argument that you're always going to end up with a lefty
government,
I suspect as the guy leading this thing.
You don't buy that argument.
I don't the longterm I don't buy that.
But actually it is the only argument that my opponent,
the Conservative Party of Canada has.
Um,
so that's their whole thing is oh yeah,
you vote for this guy,
you're going to fracture eyes.
They have a weak leader.
There's no conviction there.
Uh,
you know,
the conservative or doing a lot of polling,
polling and focus group and survey,
but they are not doing politics by conviction.
And I'm doing politics by conviction and we must speak about what we believe
openly with passion and conviction.
And that's what I'm doing.
That's a big difference with me and Andrew Scheer and Andrew Scheer,
uh,
tried to please everybody.
And he said,
actually,
uh,
and he was with the Toronto Sun and he said,
my party,
here's a centrist centrists praying metic politics called party or open for a
lot of ideas for a lot of people.
So what his thing is,
he doesn't have any principal.
You guys won't have any conviction,
doesn't have any vision for the country.
He wants to please everybody.
But at the end when you please everybody,
you end up pleasing nobody.
So that's their conservative.
I'm not,
I think I'm not happy with him,
but they're telling me,
Maxine,
we want to win.
And yes,
you are splitting the vote by dancing in a democracy.
The vote,
it's always split.
If you don't one,
any one to speak the vote,
it would be a dictator.
You don't have so,
so why don't telling them if Andrew Scheer,
when I was with him when I was a conservative,
um,
you wasn't winning against your stent could do,
it was always six to eight points behind Justin Trudeau and Maxim Biani is and
that would handle a sheer right now and uh,
end or shooters that winning is behind behind those things would all buy four to
six point now.
So he is not able to win.
So when I'm seeing two people vote for your values,
vote for what you believe in,
be part of the change.
Be with us.
We have dement on right now we have Darriel real conservative policies and ideas
and come with us and with would see what will happen.
Maybe we can be,
we can have the balance of power in,
in a parliamentary system.
Uh,
we can be in power.
So,
I don't know.
I don't know what will happen,
but I know that we have the momentum and so you think it's a risk worth taking
regardless,
even if even if at the end of the day the party splits or not the cause,
it's two separate parties but the votes are split enough that you end up with
Trudeau.
Again,
you think it's just longterm,
it's what you have to do.
Lastly,
you have to vote for what you believe,
you know,
and I'm giving them another alternative and you know why you will vote for a
politician that is telling you something and at the end he won't do any reformed
me,
won't do anything because he will look at Nepal and he won't be able to do that.
I'm speaking about real conservative reform before,
after and during an election time every time.
So yes,
that there's a risk of it here that just stayed.
It could all be erected,
but maybe you will have,
it will be erected on the,
as a manner of the government.
And if it's a minority government and we are there with a lot of seeds,
we can be the difference and we can impose or reform to the government or we
reverse the government.
We don't know what we can do,
but I don't know what can happen,
but I'm telling them that's a risk.
But you know,
vote,
vote for what you think will be good for this country in the long term.
That's what we're doing right now.
We the the like the Paul,
that's why I'm telling you,
that's the only argument that the Av,
uh,
but the goal,
and I think I can defeat just stated,
but with the most important from me actually,
it's to be able to have candidates all across the country in every writing and
we'll be able to have that.
So we're not original party where are a national body in Quebec and outside
Quebec and all across the country.
And also I'll be,
I will be present at the national debate on,
on the national TV during the,
during the election campaign in September,
October.
And that will be important for me as the leader of a new party to be there.
And I think I'll be able to questions the other leader to challenge them and
that will help our party at the end.
So we can be a big surprise.
And I'm telling people,
come with us,
voted for what you believe,
be part of the change and,
and we'll be able to do something.
I don't know what would be the end result of all that,
but I can tell you that we are able to change the country for the better.
Yeah.
That,
that should be the ending.
But I'm not quite,
I'm not quite done yet.
But that was,
that was,
that was the ending portion here in a way that was your,
that was your closing stump speech there.
What do you make of um,
sort of the state,
we haven't talked at all about religion.
It's one of the themes that we've talked a lot about here.
And I know you're obviously familiar with Jordan Peterson work,
um,
that it seems that the way that Western countries have,
say,
moved off of Judeo Christian values,
that they've replaced everything with a big state.
I actually don't know what you're
oh yeah,
they're the,
yeah.
Actually that's,
that's I believe in that.
And then that happened in Quebec in my own province in Quebec at the plane show
love or you know,
we had the relationship with the state and the church in Quebec,
Indonesian teen 15,
1960 16 and,
and after her dad,
you know,
we,
we did at the plane Shola Bala quiet revolution.
And so we were pleased we were appraised,
did the church by a bigger state and that had been in Quebec and we're still
have a big fat government at the plane.
Charlotte Laval in Quebec.
That's why,
you know,
Quebec,
uh,
is a,
a poor province in Canada.
We have a kind of a formula in Canada under our constitution.
We called that the equality station,
uh,
formula,
the rich balances are giving money to poor provinces.
And Quebec received equalization one year for the last 50 years.
So,
so because bad economic policies have to play and show Lovell and because of a
big state at the punch level,
cause it's sort of work,
there's no sure thing the money ever work.
Why did they have to do it for 50 years if this was so the good policy.
But,
but in the like too
to give some money and too,
but so,
so what you're saying about the re when I think we did that in Quebec and at the
federal level with the total government,
they want to be go to state.
Absolutely.
So I agree with Jordan when he said that when,
when he said that,
uh,
that was the case at the Brian Show Laval in Quebec or it a bit more evident but
also at the federal level.
So people want,
politicians wanted bigger government and,
and the,
the,
the more bigger to government he is,
the more power the APP,
the more regulation they are doing,
the more influence they will have.
And,
and so for,
for me,
I don't know
by that.
So that as a libertarian and government,
which as I started,
this is an odd thing because it's the only type of people that want to scale
back the very thing they're becoming part of.
Are you worried at all that everything has become political,
that it seems politics has sort of replaced sports,
at least here in the United States.
The way we talk about politicians is the way you used to talk about athletes.
We worship these people who've never accomplished anything,
but they're good on sound bites.
Trudeau has nice hair and wears Nike socks here,
although you're clearly,
you're doing all right in the sock game.
But,
but that we,
we were shipping these people who should have,
if we were doing this right,
would have almost no control over us.
And yet we,
we've elevated them to some magical state.
That's got to be just weird for you personally as someone that you want to scale
this thing back and yet you have to be part of it should be bought into that.
I have to be part of that,
to do that.
Right.
Uh,
but yes,
and I think that the population,
sometime I,
they're putting too much,
too much,
uh,
faith in a politician to change things,
you know,
and that's what I'm telling to people.
You know,
I will,
I will put forward to policies that we believe in.
But after that,
you know,
when we'll have more competition,
no more copper at welfare,
a government at respect the constitution and,
and we'll all these extreme middle to good tourism policies will,
you know,
that that is there to buy votes and ethnic voting and with different communities
will abolish these policies.
So,
and telling them,
I'll do that,
but at the same time I'm doing that because I believe in you because I don't
want to save you for every individual problems that you can have in your life.
Uh,
I want you to be irresponsible.
That's what it'll be.
It.
Uh,
but you know,
and the only politician who speak like that,
and for me,
you know,
I believe in free markets.
I believe in competition,
but when you don't have competition,
it is fun on,
in politics.
And,
you know,
Otto politician are too afraid to say that.
And for me,
uh,
that,
that's great because I don't have a political competition on what I'm seeing.
But you're right,
you know,
people must be responsible.
We must have a smaller Gutman.
And I want,
I want to have that job to be sure to do what I want to do and help people in
the right way by giving them back their,
their response of and giving them back their own money and,
uh,
giving them back.
They're increasing their purchasing power.
So all the things that if they have more money in the pot,
in their pockets that we bought,
they'll,
there'll be able to do more things.
And so for them or for their family.
So that's,
uh,
that's what I want to do in politics.
And I like that actually.
It's my best.
I'm in politics right now.
Yeah.
All right.
I normally don't enter,
end an interview asking the favor.
My favorite is this.
If you can make this thing work in Canada,
can you then send somebody down to fix the Libertarians in the United States?
Cause our libertarians need some help.
I mean,
but your,
your voice and someone that's speaking clarity on libertarian issues because we
have a lot of talkers that are doing it.
We have a lot of youtubers and think tanks that do it really well.
But for whatever reason,
and I,
again,
I voted for Gary Johnson.
I think he's a really nice man,
but he wasn't a great candidate.
We need that.
What,
what you're presenting.
So if you've got anybody,
can you,
can you send them our way when you're done with this name?
I don't deal.
Sounds good.
All right.
What was a pleasure?
Thank you so much for coming in and for more on Maxime you can check out
people's Party of Canada.
Dot.
Ca.